all right big news there from the
president and joining us now to break it
down as DW correspondent Maya shweder
she's in Washington Maya are there any
surprises here
well the biggest surprise honestly was
just the fact that this happened in the
first place the president you know built
up his image being one of these you know
tough negotiators who never backs down
and this week we saw him back down
capitulate concede one of his biggest
points really his signature policy was
building this wall and he was shown that
he was willing to take such a drastic
measures shut down the government for
the longest period in US history so far
in order to get his way and now he's
come off of that horse shall we say and
agreed to reopen the government really
in the face of declining poll numbers
and a relentless li- news cycle against
him in so many factors that have built
up to this moment including his own
staff telling him that he was losing
ground in this fight so honestly it's
just kind of extraordinary to see him
even out there conceding the point and
saying that he's willing to move forward
even just a little bit that he said I
mean this was the 35th day of that of
that shutdown it seemed like it would go
on forever why now why did this come to
an end now well there are a couple
factors here one is that yesterday we
saw both houses of Congress put up bills
proposed bills that would have ended the
shutdown and all of those attempts got
smacked down by the various opposition
parties working against each other and
once that happened once both parties had
a chance to publicly smack down the
other ones proposal then the both sides
in the Senate were able to come together
is sort of in the back rooms and start
working out a deal we think that that's
probably what happened here so now that
both sides were able to say okay here's
what we think we can do moving forward
then they presented it to the president
but the other factor in here is the
other big breaking news of the day which
is that the longtime associate closest
associate of the president Roger stone
was arrested early this morning local
time the president coming out
giving this big breaking news that's
dominated the news cycle for the past
month the fact that he's reopening the
government it was definitely a savvy
media way to push this story down
all right well but this is of course a
temporary measure three weeks of funding
for the government so what happens after
February 15 we heard the president
they're alluding to perhaps using his
power to declare a national emergency
which is something that people had been
expecting from the get-go they thought
that he would have just a few days of a
shutdown and then declare a national
emergency to get the funding for this
border wall now we see him threatening
to do that again it's likely that would
happen I feels like the president would
rather just do that than face another
government shutdown on the heels of this
one that just ended three weeks of at
least some temporary calm in Washington
Maya shweder thank you very much